Hello!
Guys, give me a sec.
Let me finish my pizza.
Let me finish my slice of pizza.
I didn't eat lunch.
Um...
You guys, guess what I was doing?
Oh, hey, didn't see you there.
Guess what I just did?
Had sex, undressed, saw her boobs.
No, I had pizza, sorry.
Had Marvel rivals undressed, saw her pizza and the rest.
Um...
I...
I was...
Um...
Playing Marvel Rivals.
I got home yesterday.
Played Marvel Rivals.
I woke up.
I played Marvel Rivals.
And then I ordered pizza.
You know?
Oh, man!
That was some good Marvel Rivals.
Gotta get a cigarette and a pizza.
I don't smoke, by the way.
Um...
But, um...
I didn't eat lunch.
So then I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay, I should actually grab something to eat.
So I got pizza.
Yay!
I got my hot honey pepperoni pizza.
I love hot honey pepperoni pizza.
It's like my newest favorite.
I used to have...
I think it's like my current favorite pizza.
Um...
Pizza.
What's it flavor?
Pizza topping.
Okay, like when you're like, what kind of pizza you want?
I want the the hot honey pizza pepperoni pizza.
It's so good I don't know when it started I also ordered popcorn chicken too because I love chicken That's not back yet.
That was like I was like, um, you come back tomorrow.
I'm, sorry.
I like I love you but like I'm tired I was like, can you take care of him for like an extra day and And the owner that not the owner No, shit.
It's i'm too far gone.
He's too far gone and i'm too far gone.
Sorry
The babysitter was like, yeah, I can take care of him Wait, I need to show you guys.
Okay.
I'll show you guys a picture i'm gonna be like, okay Um, but I need to show you a picture and when I saw that i'm like it's it's too late for us
It's too late Neppers, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
The concert was amazing Was bringing some scuff but saw none great energy missed so many wisp goons doobers That's gonna be so hard to keep track of who I met and still haven't met.
Congrats on all the wins So you think of magenta soup?
Okay, let me show you i'm gonna show you the Um, but thank you again.
I really appreciate appreciate all the dragoons that And wisps that were there All right, i'm gonna show you two pictures and then you'll know what I mean
I gotta send those two pictures and I was like, it's over It's over You know, like when I when I took him to the um To the babysitter to meet up with her He was he knew instantly that we were meeting up with her because like we were like because like he knew because I was I always carry this bag of like his treats and stuff like all His like his food his treats his leash his collar like all of all the stuff Then he saw me holding it and he got so excited.
He's like he was pulling onto he was pulling me I brought him downstairs.
Um, because I had to walk to her He was like pulling onto the leash and he's like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Today's that day Today's the day Like i'm like i'm the babysitter at this point And she's like today's that day He knows he knows he's like oh my god.
It's today.
Today's a special day.
We can finally go home Oh my god Oh, yeah, also if I make sure I oh whoops, I Make sure I shield this too Anyway, you guys if you guys know I have a nendoroid.
Whoa All right Where's the oh, I should pin that by the way Oh my god, did you guys see my nendoroids on the bestseller on amiami and the website nendoroid website?
I was so I was so happy because like It's so surreal to see that it actually I don't know like for me.
It's so surreal to like see myself um uh being like You know like like the bestseller It was both on the nendoroid bestseller and also amiami like I used to really I used to buy like lots of figures on um On amiami so to see myself in the top 10 rankings was fucking crazy I was I was just I was not expecting that at all.
I'm trying to find my link guys.
I'm a professional Um, I haven't streamed a bit.
So like that's a lie did my off collab but like i'm a Professional.
Okay.
I think it's this link good smile Okay, here we go.
Um Nendoroid pre-orders up now uh us link Us Okay, wait.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm trying to i'm trying to do The thing okay us link and then i'll do the jp one too nendoroid And I think this is jp and then us and then International All right, that should be it All right.
There you go.
I'm a professional.
Let's fucking go Um, what was I saying?
Oh, yeah, I was gonna show you the picture.
I'm all over the place right now I'm I close my eyes.
I'm thinking of him uh marvel rivals Ha ha ha ha I'm thinking of her right now.
So I got sent this picture and uh, I close my eyes.
I'm thinking about i'm Groot i'm Groot I It's like I sent this picture and then and then I was also sent And I was also sent this picture and I was like, oh he's not coming back
He he doesn't see me as I'm the babysitter now
Yeah, he's just like no please Don't take me away It reminded me It reminded me of this tweet I saw today um or yesterday um, where it was like, um, this guy's cat disappeared because like this guy was allergic to cats But he still really wanted a cat but he was also like poor And then so like the cat ran away And found a rich owner And then the guy found his cat on like he saw his cat at a window and then the guy's driving like parking Like the garage had like a porsche and then he was like,
oh, I understand
The cat's a gold digger there's a fucking gold digger
The fact that the the cat ran away to a rich guy's house that's so fucked up
So like it's like I when I pick him up he's gonna be like no
No, no mommy don't let her take me away
All right, let me put away my food real quick We didn't have a natural way to eat.
We didn't have a natural way to eat We didn't have a natural conversation
All right Putting the food away anyway today we're just gonna hang out because um Well today was gonna be like the stream where I do the stream and then we're gonna be on a little break but then I forgot my manager was like Yeah, I was sponsored stream like like they didn't know I was gonna stream today Because they thought I was taking I was taking my break today Starting today because I didn't put my waiting room out So they didn't know I was gonna stream today And they're like,
what do you mean?
What do you mean?
You're streaming today?
You have a stream tomorrow I was like, what do you mean?
I have a stream tomorrow I was just like um, no I'm streaming today because I want to take my break right after that and they're like you have a bandai sponsored
I was like
so so The thing is and then I remembered because like we were setting up the date because okay I had a choice of either streaming it before I left to atlanta Or like after I came home, so we're streaming sinuality again because there's a beta test open.
Um, the The beta test is like open again.
So we're streaming that tomorrow Uh to check out the new beta tests and the new updates and stuff like that.
So that's at 5 p.m Pst tomorrow and then after that I would break until the apex tournament, which by the way I still don't have my full team yet because I fucked up because there's like, um the point system.
I didn't realize the point system um, because I okay, this is how um, I need to like find a replacement team member because apparently the points I The points weren't over.
So that's why I I need to figure that shit out by today because the tournament's on the 20th so the reason why is that um I always see how I see predator was like because I have two predator badges um in my head I see season one As a as an as a apex season so like it's apex one two and three So if I go by that order,
I have apex two and three print badges, but regular people Regular people see it as season rank starts at season two and in two three four so like When so there was a requirement That was like oh you get lower points if you haven't touched pred in a long if you have only haven't touched pred in a long time But it's only two and three So I thought I was two and three season two and three But then I found out my print badges were actually season three and four Because like I miss I count differently compared to the regular people because like I see like this apex rank says System starts at one,
but then regular people would say apex rank season starts at two So my prep badges are three and four So like and then they're like you missed and then I got the message they're like, oh you submitted the wrong point system Because and then they and then they sent me the tweet of me being like ranked 20 Watson and My friend number break ring friend number 23 I was like,
yeah, that's four years ago.
But yeah, but it's season four
Fuck and at first I was gonna argue I was like, what do you mean?
Three and then reread this I was ready to argue and then like and I read it and then
Also like I just finished the concert so I was really tired so I was just like what a fuck you be Like that was four years ago.
You can't put me up to that standard and then I was like Three and that reread what they wrote and I deleted my messages Oh, no, I'm wrong never Never mind.
I was like just woke up to like it was like a day after the concert I just woke up and then like and then I didn't I was like, oh wait my bad, I Hope they didn't see it Because it was like late at night for them.
Wait, let me I'll show you guys what they said Look, I won't show you the message sent me but what they said like the picture they sent me and I was like, oh, I'm wrong When I saw that I was like, oh, sorry
So like they sent me it they sent me this and They were like they were like cuz like oh my god, I need to lock this I don't know why this isn't
Know why which one was it?
Which is this?
Okay, it's that so they sent me this so you see is like 28 But I was like, yeah, that's me it literally says jokey bird This is when I actually play the game, but then I was like, I was like, I was like what?
Yeah, but I thought that Cuz they were like they were like the point so like I'm my points are higher My points are high even though this was four years ago.
Cuz this is when I actually play the game now I just play Marvel Rivals.
So They said that to me and now I was ready to argue with them because I like that's four years ago It says I can do two and three and then cuz I thought that was season three, but that's season four Cuz like they don't count season one I count season one because season one to me is when rank started When rank didn't start I call it season zero because there was no rank,
but then I was wrong
So I got a reef rethink the team I got like I got like reorganize the team and everything So that's the issue anyway, all right, so Congratulations dragons you guys won a best fan base of the year I am so proud of you guys That you guys got your your own.
Oh wait.
Yeah, they send me like my manage my other manager.
I have two managers so What's funny?
Is that?
Um During the okay.
It's so funny during the one of my managers Cuz they're like my they're mostly my events manager JK They're not just my manager manager the one of them is an events manager and the other ones the manager manager So the events manager actually went to the concert.
They went to the went to the Atlanta concert So they were helping me and mint behind the scenes a lot He was basically our gopher, but it's okay I pay him so I thought I was really funny cuz like I Was like men was like asking him for stuff and like I was asking him for stuff,
too And then like and then she was like, oh man, I feel a little bad.
It's like it's okay.
I pay him
But I don't pay him I was just like no, it's fine You can you can boss him around if you Cuz he was like getting us water getting us like getting us water getting us like
And like helping us grab stuff asking things for us like we were like, oh, can you ask like the organizers if could they do this and that for us and like And everything and I was like, oh I was like man, it's okay you can ask him for stuff like He's here then look after us so it was great so So I thought it was really funny what was I gonna go with the story?
Oh my gosh I like all over the place cuz I just my head is just Marvel My head is just like 85% Marvel rivals 15% other so like I'm like all over the place right now.
Oh Yeah, the concert of work so the event manager actually does like Like I'm like like his main job actually works for mythic But he's like he does like he's like my event manager on the side And like mythic knows this So like he helps me with so it's separate by the way,
it's actually like separate.
So like he actually helped worked on the vtuber award stuff so he's like he's like he's been doing a vtuber award stuff too and it was really funny because like He was like sending me PNGs of the awards.
I won and I was like, oh, yeah.
I know.
I know I want it
But like he sent me like PNGs of the award like the you know The oh wait, he didn't send a dragon one.
Oh my god.
He only said wait.
No, do I have the other one?
I think I have the other one too.
Do I?
Just save it.
Let me see.
Give me a sec.
I think I saved it right on my phone It's on my phone or is it just also FPS?
Oh, no, I just have one for me.
Sorry guys I thought I had one for you guys, but he forgot to send that one for me I Was gonna give it to you guys, too.
I got this I was gonna give this to you guys, but it has like best fan base, but like I guess I guess only I have it
You forgot to send another one for you
Whoops I was hyping all that up just to find out that I don't even that I don't even have the You guys I'm gonna put on me I'm gonna put on the other table I'm gonna put it here Yeah, you guys can you get you dragons can play with my award.
That's right.
You dragons over there can play with it Where's our trophy?
It's alright, so yeah, you just pretend that says best fan base right there I just wanna say Congratulations he has For a winning best families, honestly, I'm so proud of all of you guys for winning it I think no other families deserves it more than you guys.
I mean you've been through a lot Yes, I mean we all been through so much together, but we came back stronger than ever and like I'm so happy you guys managed to win this award.
Like I was like, oh if I only win one I really hope it's best fan base just for you guys.
I don't care about the others.
I just hope that you guys win best fan base This is why the other managers are favorite.
Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you PDD.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
Welcome So, um, yeah, I'm super proud of you guys I'm super proud of the community I built I'm super proud of all you guys individually and all you guys together like dragoons strong together as always And yeah, I'm so proud of all you guys for winning it your first.
I don't know if it's your first award I'm happy that this is your first award and you guys 100% deserved it.
So I'm super fucking happy you guys managed to manage to win this.
Like I said like You've been through guys been through so much, but we end up becoming stronger than ever And now we don't know what to do with all these W's like I feel like every week.
There's There's something there's something new Every week we have something new to like To look forward to and I'm super happy that you're part of the journey with me But yeah, I haven't unpacked yet.
I literally okay.
I literally Unpacked my suitcase just to get my keyboard so I could play Marvel Rivals.
That's
So weird don't have a problem I swear to God I I did not unpack anything else I was like, I need my keyboard.
I need my wooden keyboard and That's really all I got Nothing else but just the wooden keyboard.
Um, oh My god, okay The concert.
Oh, let me show you some pictures of the concert Stuff from the the concert.
Let's see.
Oh and then I went to I went to what's it called?
AWA.
Oh Also, here's a little thing.
I can show you guys a little hi Because we saw like the recording of it like the recording of the The concert of Like what was recorded at the concert?
so I'll give you guys a little a little treat a little treat that got a little HD treat
You see
Oh, there you go.
Hello.
Hello HD treat for you guys.
I'll show it to you guys.
I Didn't think I'd have cat ears or a tail That was like a huge surprise.
I'd see I saw myself pop up and I was like, whoa I have a cat tail and ears.
Whoa Oh, I'm sorry, I literally just took a screenshot Sorry, that's all I could give you I saw like one time I just took a screenshot and that was it like that was Sorry, it's not I'm taking away.
Yeah, I did one good thing today I did my good deed of today and you're complaining now.
I'm going back to this vod and editing the picture out.
That's what
I'm gonna go back.
If you complain, I will take it away from you guys.
Don't complain No, we're sorry.
Yeah, that's looking right.
That's it now.
Apologize
Next see they give us super chat thing.
You think you turn those W's into WWE.
They give us super chat.
They get.
Thank you Proudly give us super chat thing.
Thank you.
Yo doki congrats on way such great awards and always know we'll have your back Wherever you need it have these flowers and sing for dad.
Cheers to you always Also, you admit be keep beware of angry moon.
She think even a super chat profit you think an affiliate They give a 10 get this shit.
Thank you.
Thank you and Kevin.
Thank you for the five get the ships.
Thank you.
Thank you That's crazy.
I bought I bought so much at Awa, I think I spent a thousand plus dollars There because like I'm sorry There were so many artists Stuff there were so many things at the at the exhibitors slash artists What did I buy?
I bought clothes.
That's what was making us so expensive.
There's so many cute clothes Like I need a new wardrobe In general, I need a new wardrobe and everything because a lot of my clothes are like getting old and old old cuz I usually Don't shop for clothes that much anymore So I have like a lot of clothes that are like you like,
you know Three plus years old for like not even three like four to five plus years old So I was like, oh man, I'm Oh USC No it's one more than 1k USC cuz like I had to log into my bank account and like pay off my credit card like
Like at the almost the end of shopping I hit my credit card limit So then I had to like log in to my bank account on my phone to pay off the limit So like so I could
Use up all the limit in the artist alley It was because like, um, I have it so that it pays off a set amount of money But a credit card every month so it doesn't pay it all the way So obviously it builds up a lot late over time because like, you know,
it just gives like a set amount It doesn't like it doesn't like it's just auto pays So like obviously it builds up closer Closer to the limit so I had to like so then like I didn't realize I already hit it like I was gonna hit it I could have paid it off before I went to Atlanta,
but like I you know, I'm fucking stupid
It doesn't matter as long as I Always pay it as long as it auto pays it off.
It's fine for me So like I don't always have to lock so I don't have to log in just to pay off my credit card limit Because I always pay it off.
It just does the auto thing and also like it doesn't really matter Anyway Kaz, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
We're incredibly strong and very happy We got an order alongside you.
Concert was super fun.
Met a lot of dragons face to face You did a great job on the dancing thing.
Very proud of you.
Looking forward to meet to the next concert I hope we get a next concert.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you I do hope we get next another concert together or maybe so I don't even know if I could get solo concert My singing abilities.
I got a mooch off someone who's a better singer and dancer So I could be the plus one.
I'm just Ken bump bump.
Someone will be the Barbie and I'm the Ken on the side I'm the Ken on the side Cypher, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Apologize to my wallet.
I never spent this much on merch in my life I'm so happy for you.
I'll keep buying.
Thank you for the super chat Cypher I'll keep buying merch.
Speaking of merch, speaking of merch, if you guys didn't know the Bouncy Hunter Acrylic stands have been shipped out.
I didn't realize GamerSup also sent you guys Some of you guys, I don't know if they sent it to everybody But like I saw pictures where like you guys got the GamerSup's like cup noodle alongside.
Yeah, the free ramen So you guys got the free ramen alongside So that's like the apologies that it was so late.
So like you guys got free ramen on the side of the Acrylic stand so for this also like you guys didn't know there is a plastic plastic top on the acrylic stand So make sure to peel that off and you see there's scratches on your stand.
They're not scratches It's like it's just it's just a plastic covering all of it up.
But yes GamerSup's is my new distributor And I thought it was just very convenient because like, you know, they already are They like they already well are well-versed with everything and as long as like I As this is like the test run.
This is our test run with GamerSup's regarding being my new distributor for Merchandising.
So, um, so yeah, we'll see it.
Well, I think it's going pretty well.
I think like you guys are Receiving your stuff and you you got free cup noodles You got free cup noodles along the side.
So I think that's a win-win for all of us.
Um Let's see, what else did I want to talk about?
Oh, yeah, I was gonna show you guys pictures I think like when I saw the giant dragoon and wisp What I got in Flables.
I thought it was so funny.
I thought it was so fucking cute.
Holy shit I wish I could like I wanted to bring it one of them home But I feel like I don't think it's possible I don't know if it's actually possible to bring but it was so cute.
Look at like look at the inflatable Oh, yeah, they killed they killed both of them though to be fair They got deflated The production value Shout out to OshieSparks because the production value for all of this was fucking insane Like a lot of these we didn't even know what's happening Until we arrived at the venue like,
you know like the thing that the bottom the video that was playing the videos that were playing and then the The body like they changed the stuff in the bottom screen to like we didn't meant and I've never seen it before So like it was so cool to see it like live and like see like seeing it all of it Like all the little features and everything to personalize and like all the things was like such a cool experience um But yeah,
I thought it was like I thought it was so cute the little inflatables and then you guys have to watch them die The people were at the venue at the watch them fucking die right after the concert
That was That was oh, yeah, and then I saw some dragoons and wisps actually went to Waffle house too right after I saw it on the tags me.
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Thank you I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much um Yeah, I saw some people were like Task accomplished.
We are at waffle house Cuz like I'm like, you know, I'm like guys we should all go to waffle house Man, I did not go to waffle house, by the way
We did not go to waffle house But like we're happy that you guys went for us.
Oh here.
This is what I want to show you guys I bought this.
I thought it was so funny.
I had to buy it.
I I'll give you a little fan service today because I thought this was funny.
I bought this
But booty shorts cuz I thought it was funny a little cheeky
I Bought myself some booty shorts.
So this is like the what?
Once a year, I'll give you a crumb of fan service now.
You gotta wait wait No, oh wait, this is 2025 fan service.
Sorry.
We've used 2025 fan service so like now you don't you don't expect anything in 2025 don't
Now you don't expect anything in 2025 No Is this not enough is this crumb not enough to feed you guys for the rest of the year is Not enough.
It's yeah, but I gave you a bonus 2024 fan service was literally the concert.
Okay, 2024.
I fed you guys We're so hungry.
Oh, what's the concert not enough God you guys are so
What's that concert not enough for 2024 this is your 2025 crumbs fan service crumb of the year
I Ghost of men.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Give me a annual fan service on my 29th birthday I am eating good tonight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear go.
Oh, it's happy birthday to you.
Yeah
If I keep booty shorts does not make you happy then you that is not me it's an internal problem It's not what I don't think I can fix
Oh My god, okay, I thought this was funny.
I want to show you guys another picture.
I thought this one was really funny basically, there's like a Green room that like we meant and I were like sitting while we're waiting for stuff to get set up and then I had to look at this isn't I had to look at it for like hours and then I Looking at it and I was like
So they were like zebras in the fucking green room and I have to look at this fucking zebra for For like at least two hours and he's like and my suffering please And me.
This is what I had to look at for at least two plus hours.
Oh!
Oh, here's some of the clothes I bought.
It was so cute.
I need to show you guys this.
I don't remember the artist, so if anybody knows the artist...
I'll post pictures of all the stuff I bought another time.
Because, like I said, I didn't unpack yet, so maybe I'll do it tomorrow.
Today's a Marvel Rivals day.
Today's important.
Today's catching up Marvel Rivals day.
I'll unpack tomorrow.
Look, it's so cute!
Look!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I bought a bunch of jackets and hoodies from this artist.
But I bought like... I bought the cat jacket, the space cat jacket, and the sheave hoodie.
And then I also got... There was like other stuff too, but I thought it was so pretty.
So I bought like a lot of...
I bought like a lot of clothes from AWA.
I think most of my merch was literally just clothes.
Because I love... I just love how creative artists are with like designs.
Like the hoodies designs and then the jackets and shirts and everything.
And I needed a new wardrobe because...
Oh no, I bought an empty suitcase.
Well, not an empty suitcase.
My suitcase, my check-in bag just had like, you know, my laptop and stuff.
And then a pair of clothes for one day.
Like outfit... like clothes for... change of clothes for one day.
And then when I came back, basically my entire suitcase was stuffed with merch.
And like with merch, with like stuff I got from the concert, with like stuff I bought from AWA and everything.
It was just fucking stuffed to the brim at that point.
Like it was so fucking heavy after that.
So like I was ready.
I knew I was gonna shop a lot.
I knew I was gonna... I knew I was gonna fucking...
Yeah, one pair because I literally arrived on the 14th.
I... I took a late night flight.
So I arrived on the 14th and I was ready to go.
I was ready.
But yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like I said, Finn and I didn't go to AWA together.
Because like we were worried that like separately we'd be fine.
It won't be like recognizable.
But like together it might be bad.
Oh yeah, when I bought... so like I didn't buy most of the...
Okay, the thing is I only bought Doki merch once.
And then after that, I had my... not my event manager, not my manager.
But like I had a personal... like I said, I had a personal chauffeur.
From the organizer gave me a personal chauffeur to help me take me around.
And like take me to places.
So like the thing is like I got worried because I saw a lot of dragoons and wisps walking around.
I saw... I saw a lot of them.
And how do I know they were dragoons or wisps?
You'd know.
Because they were wearing the phantom thief or like Doki happies.
And also were carrying a lot of Doki bird stuff.
So then I got worried.
So then I was like... I like texted the chauffeur.
And I was like, can you come here to help me buy Doki merch?
Because I... because like the thing is...
Okay, the thing that worried me the most was that there were a lot of guys too.
So like... so like...
Which is understandable because I know my percentages of viewership of guys versus girls.
And like I think my... I think like I have 20% female.
I think it dropped down to 15%.
But like... it's like 15 to 20% female audience.
And then it was like... and the rest are like male.
So like... so there's a lot of guys.
And I felt like, oh no, I'm like the only girl trying to buy Doki bird merch on this table.
So I'll be like, will they know?
So I was just like... I was like, okay.
So I was like, I shouldn't.
So I called... I called my...
Like it was at that table.
There was a table that had like Doki bird stuff.
But then there was also a lot of guys there too.
And I'll be like the only girl walking up and be like, I'd like a Doki bird merch.
So then I was like, oh my god.
This is gonna be... I'm so paranoid.
I was so paranoid.
So I was like...
15% is a high amount for blending in.
They'll think you're the 15% Doki.
Yes, but I'm paranoid as fuck, guys.
So I called the staff to be like...
Hey, can you like, you know, come over and like buy my Doki stuff?
I did it for one table.
And then...
The...
They were asking me...
Because I bought like...
I bought like Doki and Mint stuff.
And like, I think like...
I bought like Doki and Mint and some other stuff.
So obviously it would seem like I'm going to the concert.
And then they were like...
Oh my...
I'm not even gonna say who of course.
Because then it will narrow me down.
So they're like...
Are you going to the concert?
And I was like...
Yeah, I'm going to the concert.
Oh, you too?
I was like...
I'm so excited.
And then...
After that, I called...
I texted the chauffeur.
And was like...
I need you to buy Doki Burn stuff.
I was like...
That's...
That's way too close to comfort.
That's way too close.
Not for comfort.
So...
So yeah.
After that, I was like...
Alright, I'm not buying my own merch anymore.
With all these dragoons and wisp roaming around.
That one dragoon.
Wait!
Pretty sure...
There's a lot.
I'm pretty sure I'm not the only one that was asked that.
I'm pretty sure.
But yeah, after that, I was just like...
Nope, not buying.
No, I didn't laugh at all.
I was by myself.
So there was no way for me to laugh when I'm by myself.
Just walking around shopping.
Also, I bought so much.
I don't know if I told you guys.
I bought so much stuff.
That...
Afterwards, I texted the chauffeur.
To come over.
So I could drop the stuff I have.
And then went back in shopping.
I thought I was holding on to.
I was like, oh man.
It's so heavy.
But I still need to shop.
He come over so I could drop my...
So I could drop all my things.
All the things I bought.
And then go back in.
He was like, yeah sure.
I was like waiting.
Here's the drop off.
Bye.
And I went back in shopping.
I went back in.
Okay.
And then I saw some of you guys.
Posting your merch haul.
From AWA.
And I was like, wait, I didn't see any of these.
And I walked around a lot.
I was so tired too.
No, that's a lie.
I didn't walk around a lot.
I walked around everything.
But I heard some stuff sold out.
On day one.
I was like, day one?
Because I saw people posting their merch haul.
And I was like, I didn't see 50% of this.
I was going to be really sad.
Because I was like, oh man.
There's not a lot of Doki stuff.
I was like, aww.
There's not a lot.
I thought there would be more.
And then later I found out.
Because everybody sold out on day one.
I didn't know.
I was like, aww.
Even IRL Doki is stuck.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, aww.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
There's like wallets and stuff.
And everything.
And I was like, wait a minute.
I didn't see those.
I didn't see those prints.
I didn't see those keychains.
Where the fuck were they?
Brokenbon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Have you ever seen someone with handfuls of Doki merch?
You did not see anything.
Thank you for the super chat.
No, it's not true.
I couldn't even get...
I could barely...
I was only able to get like...
Six...
Five or six Doki things.
But there were so many.
I heard that even...
Yeah, the display stuff were gone too.
I was like...
I saw people's merch hauls.
And I was like...
I'm like one-eighth of that.
Like...
Most likely I've seen somebody walking around with Doki merch.
It's an actual dragon and it's not me.
I'd be the one person with zero Doki merch.
Because all of you guys gobbled it up.
Which I really appreciate.
I was like...
I really appreciate it, guys.
Like to see all the support.
That you guys gave the artists.
And like the love you gave the other artists, Ally.
And like...
Just like buying Doki stuff.
And supporting...
Supporting artists and stuff.
I just thought it was really funny.
I thought it was really funny.
That like...
I couldn't even get the merch.
I couldn't even get it.
Because they're all gone.
But yeah.
But it was fun.
I was only there for like a day and a half.
And...
So like obviously I didn't get to do a lot.
At Atlanta, I didn't see a doctor.
Or anything because I literally...
I forgot about that.
Like after the 14th.
I literally just...
Passed out.
And then woke up.
And I was like it's time.
I almost missed my flight.
Because I was so fucking tired.
I was so sad.
Because the...
The Atlanta airport.
The Atlanta airport looked so cool.
There's so much...
It's such a big airport.
And there seemed to be so much food.
I had to go straight to take...
When I got there.
I obviously had to leave the Atlanta airport.
When I got to Atlanta.
I had to leave to catch my...
So that I could be driven.
To the convention and stuff.
And like to the hotel.
And things.
And then when I left.
Obviously I couldn't walk around.
And it's like...
I'm so sad.
It's a mega mall.
I caught the flight.
And went to my transfer.
And then went home.
I was so sad.
I really wanted to explore the mega mall.
Because it looked so cool.
Also what really sucked.
Is the fact that...
I had a child sitting behind me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Also another thing is that...
Because I had to do a transfer too.
So I couldn't go...
There was no like direct flight.
So I had to do a transfer.
So the second flight.
I had a child sitting behind me.
And then...
And before I talk about the child.
I apparently got an exit seat.
And because like...
It looked a lot roomier.
Like the exit seats have more leg room.
So I got the exit seat.
But I didn't realize it's like a lot colder.
When you're next to the exit seat.
Because that's where the fucking door is.
Like...
That's where the fucking door is.
So like...
Obviously it's not...
It was very cold.
Anyway...
I learned.
It was like...
The cold is good.
I'm like one door away from fucking the sky.
Like...
Anyway...
So...
They're like...
When I checked my ticket in.
For...
For the flight.
The flight attendant.
That was checking me in.
Was like...
You apparently got an exit seat.
Would you be able to help out in an emergency?
And obviously.
I lied and said yes.
So...
Because like...
I don't know.
It's my first time sitting at an exit seat.
I don't fucking know what my job is.
I just thought like...
There's more room there.
No, if I say no.
They're gonna transfer my seat.
I was like...
Alright, well.
Obviously I have to say yes.
Because I want to sit there.
I want to sit at the exit seat.
Anyway.
So yeah, obviously.
I don't fucking know what my job was.
And then...
A flight attendant came over to me.
And was like...
In case of an emergency, just pull this lever.
And then I was like...
That's so much responsibility.
I could pull this like...
Intrusive thoughts.
Coming in and was like...
I could pull this lever right now.
Like...
That's all...
That's all I could think of.
I was like...
I could pull this lever right now.
I'm joking.
No.
So...
I don't think I should sit there.
Again.
I don't think I should sit at the exit seat again.
Also because it was really fucking cold too.
There's also that.
It was a really fucking cold...
Area to sit in.
And I was not happy.
About that.
And there was a child sitting behind me.
So the child sitting behind me was...
I think it was like...
I don't know if it's like...
Her first flight or whatever.
But this child was...
Oh my god, this child was so annoying.
She was like kicking my seat.
And then mom was like...
Honey, please don't kick the seat.
If you do that, karma's gonna come.
And I was like...
What the fuck?
Karma's gonna come?
I was like...
What kind of fucking warning is that?
You'll get karma...
If you keep doing it.
And then...
She was like...
She kept opening the tray and closing the tray.
And she had a fucking...
Hot wheel.
Cause she was like...
Yeah, I'm a hot wheel driver.
I'm like... Oh my god.
I'm just like...
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
I was surprised I was even able to sleep.
During that too.
But...
See this?
Karma's gonna come when I open this fucking door.
And they're like...
Yeah, hot wheels!
But...
It was not great.
It was not great having that child sit behind me.
Yeah, kids...
I think this is the first time I've ever had a child near me.
Like, on a plane.
It's not like I'm like...
If you're a child, please get the fuck away from me.
But like, a child sitting...
Close to me on a plane.
And now I realize...
Like I said, I rarely ever do economy.
But lately, I'm like...
It's such a short flight.
You know?
It's not like I'm flying across the ocean.
So I was like...
Okay, I'm gonna do economy.
I'm gonna do economy.
It's not that bad.
And then of course, who the fuck is gonna give their kid business class seats?
Who's gonna give their child a business class seat?
Obviously.
So, like...
I was very fortunate...
To not experience...
Um...
Children until now.
And now I'm like, this is another reason why I don't want to do economy again.
This is...
I just...
I can't...
I don't think I can handle a child sitting behind me or close to me.
It was so bad.
She kept kicking my seat.
Opening and closing the tray.
And then her mom...
All her mom said was like, don't let karma get you.
And I'm like, control your child!
Don't fuck...
Do you think this child knows what the fuck karma is?
This child doesn't care!
Like...
You really think a child can process karma?
I'm like...
Just say it's wrong!
Don't fucking say you'll get karma!
Just say it's fucking wrong!
Karma is one lever away.
That's true.
Karma is only one lever.
One lever away.
I could pull this lever right now.
Uh...
Libari, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There was a really young child in business class on the way home today, but surprisingly well behaved.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because that child thinks he's better than you.
Cause you know that child's raised rich as fuck.
So he's like...
I don't...
I...
I don't need to degrade myself to...
That's the thing!
If there's a child in...
Um...
The child is better than me.
Because like...
If a child is in business class...
That child has to be the most fucking entitled shit ever.
Like...
That's all I can say.
Cause they're like...
Yeah, I'm better than all of you people.
Cause I get to sit here.
Um...
Anyway...
So that was my flight.
That was my flight home.
It was not the best of flights.
I mean, I slept most of it.
Um...
Actually, no.
The flights were okay.
Because this time I actually got the window seats.
This time for all my flights.
The only bad thing was the child.
That's really it.
All the other ones were okay.
I literally just slept the entire time.
I didn't do anything else.
I was just sleeping cause I was so fucking tired.
Anyway, I got home.
I played Marvel Rivals.
I slept and woke up.
We're gonna play Marvel Rivals in like 10 minutes.
LAUGHS LAUGHS LAUGHS Just so you guys know.
In 10 minutes we're playing Marvel Rivals.
I don't I don't have yes on stream.
I don't have a problem I just need to win one game and when I win one game, we're we're fine I just win one game so I can be diamond one You gotta feed my addiction Um, but yeah, I'm trying to think if there's anything else I want to talk about Regarding the concert and like my trip Or like the VTuber Awards or everything but like I'm just really happy that you know Like I was actually asked if I could like film some stuff for the VTuber Awards I was so busy like if it wasn't like on the same day as the concert I would have but like other than the recordings I could all I could do was just do the recordings for the speech except like the Septon's Award recordings I could do that like that was really it but then like the rest of this stuff was just like I was just way too Busy that I couldn't like I was put like they wanted me to be part of some skits and stuff I was just like I can't I'm sorry for the and I fucking I'm booked as fuck
Cheryl thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, glad you're back safe to your loved ones Also, maybe a DokiSatCom.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, I think we're doing with sure for after this so I asked it like he's down to do and I was like, you know, I'm streaming anyway, so it's it's fine I'm already I'm already streaming anyway, so like and he's streaming too.
So I just gonna hop in for a little bit We're like one game.
I just need diamond one guys guys.
We just need diamond one guys guys We just need diamond one And
Awesome Thank you, thank you, I know you're humble about it, but your dancing was really cool This concert was done in a short period of time so I can't imagine the possibilities you can do in the future I really hope there'll be more fan of thieve concert in 2025 and beyond!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you.
Yeah, it was like, um, you guys didn't know this concert was Set up organized and everything we're in three months and then one month was just the organizers getting all the logistics done of Regarding like before we haven't even picked and we were picking songs still so like one month was spent just picking songs and deciding what we want to do and then second and third month was when we actually started like Figuring out the choreo and then in dancing and like lyrics and everything So,
the thing is, I already had 3D made... was in progress of being made before the concert.
So, you guys didn't know, my 3D model is made by a person that's worked on Hololive.
That is my official 3D model.
Like, it's not like I'm gonna get another one.
So, insane quality.
Apparently, there's a lot of polygons.
Because, you guys didn't know, also, the stage was originally gonna be a normal stage.
But Min and I requested to have a custom stage, but we had to find the people.
So, I found 3D artists to work on the whole custom stage and everything for it.
I scouted people out to work on it for us in the short amount of time that we had to make the concert stage for the concert.
And we wanted it to be super personalized and everything.
And obviously, we had to send the 3D models to them so that they could scale everything together.
And create props and stuff for it.
Create the props and the backgrounds and everything.
So, it was a lot of work for them and I really appreciate them for working so hard in the short amount of time they had.
That's why I got a lot of people in it, because I didn't want to make it so that one person has to do all of it.
So, there was a whole fucking team that worked on everything.
But yeah, my modeler was the one that's done Hololive models before for their 3D debuts.
It was very, very expensive.
Because it works for motion capture, animation, and everything.
What I did show you guys that was not in the concert was that I also have...
Oh, hello Phoebe!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you, thank you!
What is this?
Phoebe from the openers?
Phoebe that did the opener for us?
Also, Skellum, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
We can have a playoff against the 2023 FPS...
I don't know.
The 2023 FPS Gamer of the Year.
Wait, no, that's me.
Well, past Doki was more of an Apex person.
Current Doki is like Marble Rivals brain rot right now.
And it's two different games.
It's two very different games.
Oh my god, yes!
Phoebe!
It's Phoebe the...
She did one of our openers.
She's one of our opener acts.
Amazing singing and everything.
Where was I?
Fuck.
Okay.
Oh yeah, I was gonna show you guys.
This technically my... Well, not technically, it is.
This is my official 3D.
Oh my god, the quality is insane though.
There's apparently a lot of polygons.
So I already had my 3D in the works before the concert.
So it was just like, obviously, it was like...
See, that's me.
Right here.
That's me.
It looks just like me.
Right here.
But obviously, I will have a more official debut with this.
With all the other stuff.
So the thing you guys didn't see, I'm not gonna show it because I don't wanna spoil it.
I wanna show it during my official 3D debut.
Is that we actually have a separate dad model.
Like, not the one that's on top of my head.
Like, one that's like a separate model in itself.
Where like, he can walk around and stuff.
So...
We weren't able to show that at the concert.
Because like, how the fuck are we gonna motion capture a fucking dog?
Like...
We're gonna put a motion capture suit on a fucking dog?
So, I do have it.
I just, we just have it.
We just didn't show it at the concert.
Will dad get motion captured too?
So yes, that is my official 3D model.
I'm not gonna, I will release it in the future.
So you guys can do like, MMDs and stuff.
Or like, animation stuff.
But it'll be after my official 3D debut.
Which I've not yet planned or anything.
I need to start planning that soon.
But I will release that after my 3D debut.
Not like, after this concert.
Because I do wanna use it for my actual 3D.
G, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The 3D looks amazing.
Thank you.
Also, for those who are wondering when we'll upload the official recording of the concert videos.
It will not be right away.
Because we wanna like, we wanna see if there's like, anything we can do to improve upon the videos and stuff.
So, we're gonna look into that.
So, or like, improve like, the quality or like, the audio or anything.
So, we'll let you guys know when.
I don't know.
I'll let you guys know when it'll be released.
But I picked Last Cup of Coffee and the FNAF song as my official uploads.
And I think Mint's gonna upload Break Stuff and I Just Had Sex.
And then Doobie is obviously gonna upload her song with us.
Which I requested if Doobie could.
Because like, you know, I figured it would be a great gift for her fans and our fans to have an official upload of it.
And I was really thankful that we had the licensing for it too.
Because originally, we weren't, the song with Doobie wasn't gonna be uploaded.
But I requested for it to be uploaded.
Oh yeah, by the way, I did Club Penguin Dance in the concert.
It's up to you to figure out which song it was that I did it in.
Uh...
Yeah, it's up to you guys to find where I did the Club Penguin Dance.
You know, Mint was supposed to do it with me and then she forgot.
Oh, you guys found it?
You guys did?
You know, she was supposed to do it with me.
And I looked at the concert recording.
And I was like, we're
both gonna do it, right?
We're gonna do the Club Penguin Dance at that part, right?
And then she did it!
It was just me!
She forgot!
It's just me doing the...
I forgot or baited.
Honestly, I won't be surprised if she baited me.
I won't be surprised.
In my head, I'll be like, this is gonna look so funny.
When we both do the Club Penguin Dance together.
Oh my god, it'll be so fucking funny.
And it was just me.
So funny.
Uh, Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I realized something while I was at the concert.
Something that's becoming increasingly obvious.
I can no longer deny.
I am small now!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no!
Also, make sure you're refilling your...
Refilling your Dokium right now.
Because, like, after tomorrow, it's gonna be sporadic when I'm streaming.
So, if I stream in the next couple...
Well, I have to stream tomorrow for the sponsor.
Anyway, guys, it's time.
Guys, I don't know if there's anything else.
Is there anything else you guys want to ask me about the concert?
Or the VTuber Awards?
Or, like, anything else that happened this last week?
There were so many things that happened this last week.
There's so many convention announcements I'm supposed to announce.
I mean, I did it on Twitter, but obviously...
Oh yeah, I received, like, all your letters.
I haven't read them yet.
Because, like, when I received them, I was, like, literally trying to check out.
Like, I was like...
I was like, I need to check out, I'm sorry.
Like, I can't stay and chat.
I'm gonna be late.
So, I haven't read the letters yet.
And, um, but I did receive a lot of, like, gifts and letters.
From Dragoons and Wisps who came to the concert.
And, um...
I'm gonna start unpacking them.
Either late at night or, like, tomorrow.
Potapot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
InflatedDragoon and Wisps at the stage were so cute.
I hope we can see real, like, cutie roomie Dragoons one day.
Thank you for the super chat.
I was, like, talking, I don't know, did I talk about it on...
Did I talk about it on the Off Collab?
I'm wondering if I want to make, like, a beach ball version of it.
Like, you know, like, and inflate up, like, you can blow it.
And then it'll, like, uh, like, it'll inflate and stuff.
So I thought it would be, like, really cute to have, like, a version.
Like, a smaller version.
Miniature version of that, too.
You hear Marvel Rivals?
Yeah, I'm booting up the game.
Oh, you guys know.
Don't worry, don't worry, we're not gaming yet.
No, we're not.
Not time yet.
It's not time.
Oh,
yeah, so, like, um...
The...
Okay, so you can tell in the concert which ones I had dance lessons for and which ones I just winged it.
Like, I didn't even know, like, what I was gonna do.
Like, I didn't really know what I was gonna do.
I was just like, what happens, happens.
So, like, obviously, it was, at best, like, two months.
Two, like, one and a half months of dance lessons.
And there was a lot of songs.
There were...
There were a lot of songs.
So I was like, okay, I'm just gonna focus on these songs that I know I sound alright in.
And then the encore one was so fucking hard.
Like...
The encore was really rough on me.
Like, it was so... Singing and dancing-wise, it was so fucking rough on me.
But...
We don't mention about the singing part of the encore.
But you can sort of tell which one...
Like, I literally was like, I don't know what I'm doing.
But, like, we'll see how it goes.
And which one I actually had dance lessons for.
Because, like I said, I had so many dance lessons that I couldn't keep up with having too many...
I couldn't keep up with, like, a bunch of songs to know all the dance choreo for it.
So, like, I tried to, like, just be like, alright, these songs are the ones I really want choreo with.
And these other songs...
I'll just fucking shake my ass.
I'm gonna play a guitar and shake my ass.
How bad can I be?
Hunter, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your concert was my very first concert.
It was so good!
I don't think anything will top it.
What if 2025?
I don't know.
I don't know if there's gonna be a 2025 concert.
But, like, I hope I do get to do another concert in the future.
Hunter, thank you for the superchat.
Your very first superchat.
Dude, thank you, thank you.
Nexi, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your dancing really felt like you.
It was so cool to see.
Thank you, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really glad.
I'm really glad you guys liked the dancing.
I didn't get to do singing lessons, though.
Unfortunately, because I was already, like, super, like, overloaded with dance lessons.
Plus, also, like, all the other stuff I had behind the scenes.
So, like, obviously, like, all this was going on.
Plus my other responsibilities on top of it.
So, like, I, like I said, I, oh, wait.
Like, what the fuck is Grandmaster?
So, like I said, there was, like, not a lot of time to, like, balance everything out.
So, I was really worried about the singing, too.
I was really, really worried about it.
Um...
So, I'm just happy it all turned out, like, good.
I'm happy everybody enjoyed it.
I think, like I said, I, like, on stream, if we ever get another opportunity to do another concert...
I won't accept it if we can have streaming tickets sold.
Because, like, I won't, because, like, you know, I know, like, we had recording of...
But, like, obviously you guys deserve, like, better quality recordings of it.
So, like, I don't mind if, uh...
But also, like, because...
Because I know a lot, I saw people were, like, really amazed that we're allowed up recordings and stuff like that.
Because, like, we thought that, like, you know, you guys didn't have, like, the only people who are there can watch it.
So, we were fine with having recordings and stuff.
Um, I mean, like, a lot of Western concerts allow recordings and things.
Because you don't publish it out to, like, there's no, like, streaming tickets or anything.
So, um, so we were fine with having recordings.
Just because, like, you know, there's no other way to actually watch this.
Um, but obviously if we have streaming tickets, um...
We won't allow recordings in the future.
Because they'll just, like, take the whole fucking...
They'll just, they'll just take the streaming...
The, the streaming...
Oh my god, I'm a single diamond!
Oh my god!
What do, I'm the, the diamond in this game!
What do I do?
Also, where am I?
Oh, I'm over here.
Okay, there we go.
What the fuck?
I'm just a...
Lonely diamond!
What am I doing here?
I'm diamond too!
Like, what the fuck?
There's no way this is balanced.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god, and then I'm healing with surefire.
I'm...
We're back in the Marble Rivals funds.
We're...
We're back here in...
We're back here in the mines.
Oh my god, alright, back in it again.
We're doing...
They're like, you had one job!
You're supposed to ban Hawkeye!
You...
We had one job, guys!
Why did we not ban Hawkeye?
We not...
Okay, we're banning strange.
Okay.
Alright, it'll be fucking funny if we got...
If it took Punisher from us.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, they got the Hawkeye in.
There we...
Alright, it's Luna time.
Yes, we're back in it.
Guys, we're...
We're back in...
Wait, I won more without my aimbot eye.
Let's take that away.
Let's actually take that away.
Guys, I don't have a problem.
I swear, it's just...
It's a really good game!
It's a really, really good game, guys.
I don't have a problem.
Okay.
It's just...
It's healthy.
It's so healthy.
I can't believe it.
I'm in a GM game.
Oh my god.
And Surefour is on fucking support.
You'd think the other team would also have...
I'm not even Diamond 1.
I'm Diamond 2.
So you'd think the other team would also have a Diamond 2 with me.
But no, the other team is just all GMs.
It's just all GMs.
What the fuck am I supposed to do with that?
Where's our tanks?
Oh, there he is.
Where's our singular tank?
Sorry, I meant where's our tank?
Whoops, I fell down.
I intentionally fell down.
I intentionally fell down, guys.
Okay.
Guys, it was all intentional.
Oh my god, we gotta get him away.
Get him away.
Alright.
Thank you.
It's very tactical, guys.
Oh my god.
I'm so stressed out already.
Oh, Pia, thank...
Oh, shit!
Hey, Pia.
This is a real content now.
Guys, this is very concerning because...
No!
Alright.
Alright, so...
I don't know what happened to Surefour there.
I looked...
I turned around and he got fucking eaten.
Okay.
Alright, where's our Ironman?
Alright, Ironman, you better fucking carry.
You're getting the...
The mark...
Wait, how did he know he had the mark?
How did he know?
I'm surprised he's playing Sharp Jeff.
I'm a little worried here.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, this is so fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh, it's fine.
We're so...
Oh, he's dead.
I don't know how he's dead, but...
Oh my god.
Don't...
Oh, I'm dead too.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
He's mad now.
We're so okay.
It's so okay.
It's fine.
See, we won the fight.
I told you guys.
What were you guys so worried about?
We won the fight, chat.
There's nothing to be worried about.
Everything is fine.
Oh, everything is fine.
Everything is still fine.
Everything is still very fine.
Everything...
Everything is okay.
I'm not stressed out.
I love this game.
I love Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god.
He's okay.
My hands are shaking a little bit, guys.
Oh my god.
My hands are shaking, but I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Iron Man, I got you.
I got you.
We dance!
We keep dancing!
Just...
Just dance!
No!
Shit.
Please.
There's a Venom.
Dance like it's my concert.
Okay, see?
I'm having a great time.
Oh my god.
He is alive.
I'm having a great time.
Holy shit.
Oh wait, there's a Bourne again.
But where is the Bourne?
Where is he gonna give birth?
It's okay.
I got you, Iron Man.
We're all okay.
Because I need more stress in my life right after the concert.
That's definitely what I needed right after a stressful concert.
Oh no.
Mad.
Holy shit.
He went to Ning.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he lives?
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
He's still alive.
Jesus Christ.
I did nothing.
Go!
Live!
Dance!
Dance, everybody!
Don't!
You died.
That's fine.
Keep dancing!
Okay.
That...
I did not think he was gonna do all of that.
That's fine.
He's so low.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Oh, and then the Bourne again.
That's okay.
That's okay, he just gave birth to one guy.
Go, Adam, go!
What?!
Okay, I did not think he was gonna...
Oh my god, please.
I'm so scared.
We got it!
No!
It's fine!
Oh no, he's not fine!
Oh, he got it!
He got somebody in!
We're so fine!
I'm fucking...
I'm skating!
I'm still skating!
Oh my god.
I don't know if I can grab ult in time, though.
No, I'm asleep!
What do you mean?!
He just appeared!
He only leaves him when he's dead!
Oh my god!
It only leaves Arman when he's dead!
I had to heal somebody!
I...
I literally...
I had to heal someone!
He's not the...
When he's not alive!
Like...
It's not like he lives forever!
Sometimes he's dead!
Oh my god.
We're all dancing!
We're still dancing!
Oh,
he's still angry.
He's still so angry.
No!
What do you mean?!
Oh, he's frozen!
Oh my god!
Why am I in a gym?!
Oh my god, please!
You're getting so many kills!
Please!
You're getting...
Oh my god, I'm trying!
Please, no!
I just need a little bit!
Just a little bit of a heal still!
No, I'm coming back!
They said...
No!
I am 98!
Oh my god.
I know, it's so... I'm so...
I'm so relaxed right now.
I'm so fucking relaxed.
I'm so...
No, they're yelling!
He's actually not even close, bro.
He's good with the Hulk passive.
But without it, he's useless.
He's obviously trolling you.
This game's not our fault, bro.
LOL
I'm healing for my fucking life right now!
This is my second time on Ironman, bro.
This is my second time on Ironman!
What's going on?
What's going on to our team right now?
It's all falling apart!
No!
LOL Dance harder, Doki!
You gotta keep dancing!
I'm hurt.
I'm scared.
I'm hurt and I'm scared.
Bro, he's flying.
He's flying so much.
Please, Ironman, don't die!
Just live!
Please!
Every resource possible is going to you!
We're putting everything into you!
If I don't, they'll yell at me and I'll cry!
LOL
Legitimately, every single resource went to him.
How are we still fighting this?
I need help!
It's okay, a minute.
You need me.
We're on a show!
Yep, I'm looking out for you.
I wish I could do it easier.
Oh my god!
How are we still fighting this?
You got a Venom on you?
Okay, there you go.
Where is he?
Just slam the wall.
Where's the Ironman?
Where's this fucker?
Alright.
That's fine.
I like how we have commers that don't even comm who they're fucking attacking.
Then why open your mouth?
Why even talk at that point if you're not even gonna say who you're gonna fucking target?
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm going for more, hold on.
Oh
my god, just slam please!
Like why use comms if you don't even comm anything?
I'm just, I don't understand!
What's the point of opening your mouth?
It's fine.
We're fine.
I'm so fine.
You better live, you fuck- Are
we okay?
Is it safe now?
I like how we just walked in the- like do we come out?
Do we come out of our hidey hole?
Are we okay?
Oh no.
What if it's again?
Please!
No!
Oh my god, they're using their mouths!
They're using their mouths, guys!
They're comming who they're attacking!
Just kill point, just kill whoever touches.
Oh my god!
Oh we're gonna, oh we're gonna commit to this?
Okay, we're- he committed!
Why did he commit?
He committed!
Oh my god.
Do they have a better team than us?
Is that it?
I'm running in the skybox.
Do they see me?
Is it cause they have- oh!
Oh goodbye!
Hello!
Oh no, not again.
Oh my god, what?!
Okay, I didn't see that.
I was like, where's that?
Where's- oh, right there!
I was like, where did that come from?
We have zero targeting.
What's the problem?
I don't know, maybe like we don't work together?
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
You're literally the first person I see!
What do you mean I don't see anybody else in front of me?!
What?
I'm only putting it on because I don't see anyone else!
Like, what am I supposed to do when no one else is in my view?!
Like, I don't- Like, please!
Winning the last lane.
Everyone loves that.
Like, I spawn in and it's like, why do I have orb?
I don't fucking know, why are you in front of me?!
Alright.
Why the fuck is this fucker in front of me?!
Okay.
Fine, that's fine.
That's fine.
Where is this?
No!
Bro, they're roasting!
They're actually flaming Shurifor!
Bro, you're so fucking stupid!
Imagine flaming Shurifor!
Holy shit!
That's actually crazy!
That man is like a fucking gamer and you're gonna flame him!
Deserved!
Holy shit, if you don't- Oh my god!
That's actually crazy.
That's- That's actually- He doesn't know!
Oh my god!
That's actually insane!
Who the fuck is- Just assume me, I'm confused.
Bro has no idea.
And the fact that I'm streaming and he's streaming too!
This bro has no idea!
He fucking roasted-
He roasted a guy who is like known as one of the best Overwatch League players.
That's actually insane!
That he got literally paid to play video games.
He's so- And he's just a fucking lowly G Grandmaster 3 on Magneto.
They don't know, they don't know I'm Shurifor.
Wait, he was?
I thought he was just a dude!
Just like some guy, you know?
Just some guy.
Alright, I'm focusing up right now.
By the way.
Thank you.
Thank you for the little poke, I got a little worried.
When I'm not full HP.
And when you're not full HP, it's a little worrisome.
Oh my god.
You're all one!
Alright, we're fine.
I know him as Doki's friend!
Oh, don't tell him that.
Don't hurt his ego.
Doki's plus one.
I have no idea, he's just a guy that's just really, really good at video games.
He's just some guy.
Yeah, he was known as one of the best Widowmakers in Overwatch League.
He also was like... I used to watch him in Overwatch.
He was like one of the most famous Overwatch streamers back then.
But he's just some guy.
Now he's gonna throw the game.
He's...
He's just a chill guy.
Okay, now he's a furry.
Sorry.
I still think it was fucking wild.
That...
That he was like...
You're fine.
Oh nice, we did it!
We won!
We fucking won!
Oh my god!
Nice, we did it.
EZ carry!
The lack of self-awareness!
Holy fuck!
He wasn't even like MVP!
Oh my god!
The lack of self- Look at that diamond one, here we go.
The lack of fucking self-awareness this guy has is crazy.
No fucking way.
That's like crazy!
Look at this dude.
Oh my god.
I can't believe he said that.
That's insane.
Wait, 22k?
Bro, he's like catching up.
Oh my god.
And we got diamond one.
That's nothing.
You're either grandmaster or bust.
Oh my god.
Stupid diamond one play, I'm sorry.
Hello everybody.
I'm the child that showed up.
You know, when they bring a child to like a group hangout.
When they bring the child.
You want to just super again?
Sure.
Yo, what's up, what's up, what's up?
I'm here, I'm here.
They banned my wolverine!
Are you throwing, bro?
They banned my fucking wolverine!
Alright, where is it?
You're already ruining your mental, so...
Uh, where's mine?
Have you just been running it on wolverine, bro?
Yes, I have!
Dude, my fucking win rate is high.
I'm nominated.
Well, not last game.
We shit on you.
Wait, what's your win rate?
Fucking 80 to 10 on wolverine?
8 to 10?
Wait, 8 to 10?
You don't know about my iron man.
If you got a hulk?
Yeah, we got a hulk right now.
No, he only won.
Oh my god.
Alright, time to lock in.
They don't know about my iron man.
Has he even played iron man?
Has he?
No longer.
Yo, check me out.
I can't check it mid game.
It's inspiring.
Alright, this will be fun.
I'll do like what they did.
Just have it on the iron man, right?
Oops, I messed up.
I have like 4 of them falling.
And 3 of them just fall out of it.
Wait, tell me if they're TPing.
One of our teammates just shit talked to you, man.
I see that, man.
I don't really acknowledge that.
They are running at you guys right now.
No TP though?
Nope, no TP.
Okay.
I don't think they're stupid.
Wait, they actually walked?
Oh my god.
We can't see you guys over there for heals.
I'm gonna go back up here.
Alright, they actually- They actually took the portal!
Is that fucking crazy?
That's so dumb.
I can't believe they actually took the portal.
That's actually crazy that that worked.
You don't expect that to work.
I need to give it to one of the tanks.
Okay, I got on the tank.
I have to heal here because I don't want to get fucking arrowed to the head.
Oh no, he's mad.
He's so mad.
It's fine.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Get in the ult!
She's one, she's one!
No!
She's so low!
What the fuck is going- Oh, he was trying to- I danced, but the dancing was no use.
I'm coming over!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh!
I danced so hard!
How much more do I have to dance?!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, Sylar?
Oh my god, he's so mad!
Oh my god, I don't know what he's doing!
He's trying to do what they did last game!
Oh my god.
Is our Hulk still alive?!
What's he doing over there?!
Okay, alright.
Nevermind.
He was still alive.
Nice.
Oh.
My god, I'm still okay.
I'm still okay.
I'm a little scared.
We're gonna dance!
We go!
Oh my god, okay.
She's frozen?
You're alive?
Oh my god, please!
I'm still dancing!
Oh my god, you're still alive!
You're still...
Oh my god, how much more?!
Oh my god, he takes so much damage!
It's fine!
Everything is fine!
Don't look at Surefour's KDA.
Surefour, what's up with your KDA?
Oh my god.
I'll do this after his.
Okay, I'll do it now!
I'll do it now!
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
Nice.
Wait, born again?!
What?
Alright, we're fine.
Yeah, this is how I celebrate my win!
I play Marvel Rivals.
That's how I celebrate.
That's how we should always celebrate Marvel Rivals.
Oh my god, the Atom gave birth to six tuplets and they all died.
That's so sad.
I hate the Luna skin.
I might buy the Christmas one.
I might buy the Christmas skin, because that one's pretty.
Guys, we're celebrating.
We're celebrating.
The concept was the pre-show for the...
For Marvel Rivals.
True.
I don't know if I said that!
I don't even keep this on him!
Wait, is my mic working?
I don't even know if he heard me.
Oh, that sucks.
I was just gonna ask if you still play Deadlock at all.
I don't know if he heard me say, what's wrong with your KDA.
I'm TP'ing!
Mine's gonna be to the right.
Mine's the good one.
What are they trying to do?
I'm right behind them.
I'm doing it fast.
Go, go, go!
What the...
What?
Oh my god, I got him.
Oh my god, that's so scary!
That's so...
That's such a scary TP!
Holy shit!
I'm so scared!
I was gonna jump!
I was so scared!
I was gonna jump into that.
Oh my god, I got fucking shit on.
Now we're thinking with portals, right?
I was like, oh my god, we're gonna accidentally walk into the fucking portal.
They try to counter the TP with TP.
That's actually fucking crazy.
That was such a crazy tech there.
That's grandmaster right there.
Oh no.
Am I just...
That's so fucking scary!
That's fucking...
That's a freaking flyswatter.
That's crazy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I had...
Oh, I'm so fucking dead.
Unless...
Oh no, I could've ulted!
No!
I fucked up.
I could've ulted there.
I didn't ult.
I was too busy looking up.
It's fine.
We're baiting ults.
Alright.
I'm gonna make sure he doesn't die.
It'll be fine.
I'm going in.
We're dancing!
He has the eye!
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
No, he's so low!
No!
He's going again!
Don't let him do it!
No, he gave birth!
Oh nice, we got it.
Alright, we got it.
Oh no, he used me for again.
When he goes again...
What do I do?
What do I do when he goes again?
I just die.
No.
Okay.
Don't worry, he'll do something with this.
Oh my god, whenever he comes in, I fucking...
I don't know what to do.
He scares me.
Whenever he jumps in like that...
It's like a fucking fly.
It's like...
It's like a fucking Hulk roll out there.
Yay!
Yeah, he won with...
He raised his win rate.
He raised his...
His Ironman win rate.
He's not wrong.
He has a positive win rate on Ironman.
He's not wrong about that.
Oh my god, they have...
They have two diamond players.
Oh my god.
I'm not alone.
Oh my god, guys.
We have one of the OG goat creators.
This is the fucker.
One of the fuckers that made goats.
That's him.
He did this.
He created...
He was part of the problem.
Yeah, that's him.
He's one of the guys that made goats.
The founder.
It's goading time.
Alright, what are they banning?
Wait, who this guy?
Kalug?
He's part of...
He was in the OG goats team.
That created one of the worst metas in Overwatch.
But they won.
They won the Overwatch.
What is it?
Open division?
He did it.
At what cost?
He won.
Basically, that's the cost.
They won.
It was open division.
Basically, for those who don't know...
Overwatch stuff but know Apex...
It's basically like pro league.
He won pro league.
Pro league.
It's not always about winning.
At least he's not in the C9 team.
Oh, you know who's in the C9 team?
Surefour?
He was part of the team where C9 originated from.
He was there.
We have history all here.
They're all here.
He was actually in that game when it happened.
He was part of it.
What?
They're like, at least it's not Cloud9.
Oh, but we have someone in there who is.
He's right here.
What about me?
I was just here.
The world is an endless circle.
They're all standing in a nice line.
They stopped standing in a nice line.
I forgot to re-bind my audio stuff.
We can kill him.
It's fine.
Nice.
Okay, we should go back to the front.
Two people with the most important esport history.
You're right.
They were all part of the most important esport history.
And they're all in this game right now.
I know he's good.
Really?
Who?
I'm gonna play my favorite spot after I drop down here.
And then play my favorite spot, which is here.
Let's hope they don't die after I turn around.
I turned around and I was like, I hope they're okay.
I'm not looking at anything right now.
I'm not gonna look at them for healing.
Because I wanna show you my favorite spot on stream.
Two out of three of my people I watch are on Marble Rivals as it should be.
Isn't that great?
Yeah, but are they in my elo?
Are they as high quality gaming as this right now?
That's right.
It is.
Okay, but are they on Luna Snow?
Are they dancing like I am dancing right now?
Are they dancing?
Yeah, that's right.
You get to see the cool ass dancing that I'm doing on the other streams.
Oh well.
Get your dances here.
Whoa, real dancing?
Oh god, please, please don't die.
Please.
Please don't die.
That's all I ask.
Don't die.
I just realized Surefour is on Moon Knight.
Wait, where's...
Oh shit.
Oh he's... Oh my god!
That block was insane though!
Okay, they're dead.
Our team's dead.
That was an insane block though!
But our team's dead, but that's okay.
At least that block was crazy cool.
Like, you know?
It's cool to watch.
Let's keep dancing.
We're all just...
I guess we just keep dancing.
That's cool.
We're still dancing!
Yeah!
We're putting on a show!
Dance the pain away!
See?
They're not dancing.
I'm not like other VTubers.
I dance in the video game too.
Okay, let's get rid of this.
I don't want to push this.
I don't want to talk to people anymore.
I only talk because Super was there.
And I know Surefour likes talking when Super was there, so I was like I want to be part of this.
I don't want to be left out.
Don, thank you for the magenta super!
Thank you, thank you!
If all else perished and he remained, I should still continue to be.
And if all else remains and he were annihilated, the universe would turn into a mighty stranger.
If your world wanted your friend dead, would you still try to save her?
Is this about dancing?
Thank you for the magenta super!
Thank you, thank you!
Is this part of dancing?
Is this about dancing, Don?
Yeah, you're welcome!
You know why he hasn't died once?
That's right!
It's me!
Yeah!
That's right!
I did that!
Yep!
What?!
Oh, I can heal from here.
Don't worry!
Don't worry, I got you!
When this portal is gone, he's so fucked!
He's so fucked!
The portal!
I'm sorry, bro!
We can't help you anymore!
We can't, bro!
I'm sorry, bro!
When you're alive?!
When he's alive?!
That is...
That's actually crazy that he lived.
I'm actually so surprised.
Well, guys...
His one...
No more one death.
He lived longer when he was away from us.
The clip portal is amazing!
Oh, surefour!
Oh!
It's okay, I'll pretend I...
Don't tell him I saw that.
Oh my god, wait.
That was weird.
I, like, lagged there a little bit.
Oh!
That's fine.
I have ult soon.
Alright.
I'm gonna save this a little bit and then I'll use it right now!
Oh!
It's fine.
That's fine.
We're dancing!
We're gonna keep dancing!
Yes!
I'm a gamer!
There we go.
There we go, we did it.
We're fine.
I counter-danced.
Easy.
I'm gaming.
Thank you for freelo.
Bro, this guy does not know we have two Overwatch legends on our team.
We literally have...
It's not because he was freelo.
We literally have two Overwatch legends.
He doesn't know.
Oh my god.
We're winning!
Yippee!
Make that three?
No, I wasn't...
I wasn't nobody.
I just loved the game a lot.
I just really, really liked Overwatch.
What even is his...
I need to check his win rate on Ironman.
Statistic.
57 minutes.
Oh shit, wait!
That's actually a really good win rate.
Wait a minute.
We gave him that.
We did lose one though.
Wait, I was not expecting his win rate to actually be that good.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Wait, yeah.
That's really good.
I guess we enabled him so hard that...
Sorry, I got a DM and it was like, oh here are some photos from the streamer and I'm just like, but I wasn't there.
Technically, I was there.
I was on the iPad.
But I was just like, how would there be any photos of me there?
I guess you just see me see my iPad.
I guess that's it.
Yippee!
That was the PNG.
That was me.
Alright.
If we win this, we'll end it.
Wait, actually, if we win, I think we need two games.
I don't think the next game...
The next game is GM.
I don't think so.
I think I need to win another game for that.
What is that?
Is Surefour top 500 yet?
What is it?
Oh my god, it's him.
For those who don't remember this guy, this was like...
I think this... Was this the Hulk guy?
Was that him?
The guy that was like, what the fuck are you doing to like, me and Surefour?
The guy...
Was it that guy?
Bro, fuck that guy.
Let's see.
It's GM3.
Is he even in here?
Let's see.
Flower...
Guys, I know I said one game.
This is still the one game, guys.
We're still at that one game.
I mean, it's GM3.
So...
I feel like GM3 is a lot harder.
It must be a lot harder.
I mean, I'm winning GM games, so...
It's not...
To be fair, I am duoed with Surefour, so...
I just enable him to do the shit he does.
Oh, he's not on it yet.
Oh, it's rank 256?
Wait, no.
No, that's not even right.
The fuck is 256?
What?
Oh,
wait.
Is he GM2?
No, he's not in there.
He's not in there.
Unless I'm spelling it wrong.
Sad.
Sadness.
How is he not there?
Wait a minute.
Wait, he's GM2?
Oh, he's 202.
God, but he's GM2 already.
He's GM2 already.
That's fucking crazy.
No wonder games are taking much longer now.
No wonder.
Oh my god.
We're too high rank.
Games are taking so much longer because we're so high rank now.
Do I recognize anybody?
No.
Not on our team or the enemy team.
Oh my gosh.
Hello, everybody.
I'm Diamond 1.
It's nice to meet you all.
It's me.
Sitting in the grown-up table.
Don't worry.
I'm wearing my big boy pants today.
Squeaker alert.
Squeaker.
Get the fuck out of our lobby.
Can I have some chicken nuggets?
I wanna be Luna Snow.
Like the moon.
Is that a 12-year-old boy or a girl?
Oh, I got that a lot.
I got that a lot.
Growing up.
I'll be like, a girl.
Remember when they were like, buy an Iron Fist.
Is there an Iron Fist player on their team?
We'll do a second one.
I mean.
No.
Oh yeah, because we have an Iron Fist player.
Oh, is Captain Raz a fucking Hawk player?
A banned Hawk.
What do I do?
No!
He is a one-trick!
How do you one-trick in GM?
Like, how?
How do you?
Last night.
Last night, I was playing in Shatter 2K.
Told me to avoid Mike, and I didn't.
But I didn't listen.
Mike!
No!
Everything's going down!
Why would you say that?
He's literally here!
And last game, my entire team told me to avoid Mike.
Okay, so.
Last night, I kept queuing into Shatter 2K, and I farmed him.
Because my team was always like ban Magic and, oh my god, he's a two-trick.
I'm trying to remember what he is.
Ban Magic and Psylocke, because he's a two-trick.
So like, he literally, if he can't play Magic or Psylocke, he loses.
And that's what I did.
I avoided him, and then I just, we just ban Magic and...
We just ban Magic and Psylocke And he couldn't do anything!
That's so evil!
I like, farmed three games off of him from that.
That's so cruel!
Because, if you're a two-trick, you're doing it wrong.
I didn't even start it, dude!
Someone on my team was like, you gotta ban this, and then I learned.
No, I'm not I can ban Luna one-trick.
I can play Cloak and Mantis.
I just like playing Luna more.
When they ban Luna, I just play Mantis.
If they ban Mantis and...
If they ban either of it, I just do the other two.
The thing is, people would rather ban the support, I mean the DPS than the support.
So they ban one support.
And then, that's all I have to worry about.
That's how you game the system.
You have to game the system if you want to climb.
You always ban people's one-tricks.
It teaches them a lesson to not one-trick.
Because then they can't one-trick anymore.
Oh no, they didn't.
I think we're gonna die here.
Don't worry, I got you.
I don't think we can contest this.
Unless... No, we can't.
No, we cannot.
No, we cannot contest this.
Oh, I'm...
My poor Mantis.
Oh.
Oh, I'm just...
Oh my god, I'm just gonna dance!
I'm...
Whoa!
Okay.
Goodbye.
You know, now I know which two players I'm fucking avoiding.
I'm fucking... Now I know.
They were right about Mike.
And our Hulk one-trick.
They were right about two people.
They were right.
That's the worst part.
Oh god.
I'm trying to help you.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Goodbye!
Nice.
He got double.
Um...
What do we do with that?
I'm... I'm dancing!
I'm...
I'm dancing!
I'm dancing.
Oh.
Oh, he's back.
No!
I felt joy for one second and then our match's rage quit.
That was fucking crazy.
Bro, bro.
Oh my god.
No!
I'm gathering!
Oh, oh, I'm...
I'm so scared.
Hey guys, hey tanks.
Oh my god!
Guys, I...
I think...
I think this is it.
I think maybe... oh, goodbye.
Goodbye, Mantis.
If you die, you die.
Goodbye, I skate.
I skate.
I still skate.
Oh shit, I might have accidentally baited him.
I'm still skating.
Oh my god, he's on Wolverine.
He's gaming now.
I believe in surefire.
I believe in him.
It's fine.
Oh my god!
Wait, that was so good.
Wait, that was pretty hot.
Did you see that?
Whoa, my FPS brain went...
went whoa.
Yeah, man, that was really cool.
Ow.
Did you guys see that?
Bro, did you guys see what he did?
He fucking slammed a rock into him and it's all...
We're dead.
Oh, we're alive.
Look, I can appreciate good gameplay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's two minutes left.
Oh, he's so low.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's so fine.
We stabilized.
Yeah, exactly.
You can appreciate good gamers.
Good gaming.
I need to learn how to aim my ice better.
Like, I do panic aim instead of, like, actually using it to, like, stop shit.
Come to my concert!
Yay!
And I leave now.
I leave now.
I... whoop, whoop.
I gotta go.
Oh, this is where we die.
This is where we die.
There's too many offensive ults.
What do I do?
Oh, no.
No way.
They're blocking the door.
Oh, no.
Go left, we go right.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Oh, shit!
Goodbye, everybody.
It was nice knowing you all.
I like how they're like, go left!
We all went right.
What the fuck?
You know, we held it pretty well after they steamrolled us for minutes.
They did steamroll us for a long time.
Not very nice.
Okay, I'm gonna avoid Captain Roz and I'll avoid Mike.
How did he get the GM?
How the fuck did Mike get the GM like that?
Of course, it would never happen.
It would never be that easy.
Of fucking course.
It's never that easy.
It was too good to be true, guys.
It was too good to be true.
We saw it.
Dude, I got like three players, three from my friends a GM.
It's so not fair.
It's um, it's actually not fair.
I played with three different people and they all got the GM with my duo.
And then like I'm still here in Diamond.
I'm so- It's not fair!
I wanna be there too!
You were left behind.
One of them was like, one of them like stopped after I needed like one game to rank up.
Not to die to GM, but to like, um...
But to like Diamond 1.
I was so sad.
I was like, but I need one!
Yeah.
Bro.
Okay, we gotta heal this guy.
Just Rambo.
Just Rambo things.
I was like, you got the GM!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
There's so much damage.
Okay, that's on you.
Why the fuck were you- He's literally one.
He's literally one.
He's one too.
Go!
Go, Mike!
Beat the shit out of him!
Oh my god, Mike!
What the fuck happened over there?
What kind of fight club did I miss out on?
Bro, I missed out on some fight club shit on the other side.
Nice.
Yeah, he does.
He heals during punches.
But you have to out-damage his punch.
Well, that'll be fine.
Yeah, I didn't ult because I was like, they'll be okay.
I- I relied very heavily on the, they'll be okay.
I had to like, hope that they'll be okay.
Oh my god, nice.
Go!
Run!
Gas!
Keep punching!
Just keep punching!
Alright.
We're going to where?
Oh!
Oh, oh, where's that portal?
Where's that?
Oh, that's where that portal is.
Hey guys.
Keep punching like your heart's desire!
Punch so fuck- yeah, keep doing it!
Keep punching!
I just watched, bro.
That fucking guy punched so fucking hard.
Oh.
Oh, goodbye.
I guess this is where I die.
I guess.
Go, buddy!
Go!
Wait, we lost that fight?
No way!
We had so many picks!
He punched so hard!
How did we lose that fight?
All he did was punch!
I can't.
I- I- I have to reload one day.
I- Oh my god!
I- Oh my- I don't know how- That's why I'm- I deserve to be GM.
This is exactly why I deserve it.
Oh my god, keep going, Mikey!
Keep punching!
Oh my god, there you go.
I am strengthened.
No, no!
Oh my god, we're always like just there.
We get like 200 picks?
Why can't we do anything with 200 picks?
Mike punched so much, but nothing happened!
All he did was punch!
Okay, we got a pick though.
I have to reload.
Please, I can't.
Okay, I have all- Okay, I'm just gonna push up.
That's fine.
Let's go!
Please!
Oh my god, please!
Are you alive?
He is not alive.
He- he is absolutely not alive.
Oh my god!
Oh, you guys are all disgusting!
Loki pissed me off!
I'm just- I'm just a Yui!
What am I supposed to do?
It's okay.
It's never that easy.
Goodbye, Mikey.
I can't wait to see you never.
What's that?
He's putting on a show!
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's fucking dead.
Haha, he's- He's so dead.
I think- I think this was a team death.
I think- Possibly.
I think it was- The team was just not there.
It was so- we had a hawk one trick and we had Mike.
We had- we had fucking Mike.
Bro, he's a little mad.
He's low-key pissed off, guys.
Low-key.
Okay, avoid him.
And where's Mike?
Sorry, Mike.
You're gone.
Goodbye, Mike.
Mike...
Mike tried his best.
I just like how- I like how he was like, not gonna lie, low-key pissing me off.
Low-key!
What do you mean low-key pissed off?
I'm just a little mad.
Just a little bit.
Oh shit, I'm gonna do what he did!
Guys, ban Hulk.
They have Hulk one trick.
Yes, sir!
Wait, was- was Ross the Hulk player?
I don't even know.
I don't- The intel.
I'm banning Hulk.
Fuck it.
I get the point.
Was it Captain Ross?
Yeah, it was.
Yeah, okay.
You're evil.
Dance.
Nice.
I'm getting back- I'm getting back my elo that I lost.
He knows.
He fucking knows.
That should be a one trick!
Hulk mad.
It's a lesson to not be a one trick!
I was like, Hulk sucks, why you ban him?
He's hulking out.
I'm not a one trick!
I can play other supports!
I just like playing Luna!
If they ban- when they ban Luna, I play Mantis or- I play Mantis or Cloak.
I do play other supports!
I did!
Don't make him angry.
I'm getting back the elo I lost from a Hulk one trick.
I say as even though we ban Hulk, he's gonna- he's gonna win.
Knowing my luck, he's gonna win this game because I ban Hulk.
Lowkey though, the fucking counter portal that one game we had was actually insane.
I think I was like, one of the crazy shit.
Wait.
I'm trying to keep our-
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Everyone's taking so much damage.
It's fine.
Oh, it's fine.
That's fine, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh, they put him on support!
They put Captain Rez on support!
Because he can't play any other thing!
Oh my god, I just noticed that they put him on support, that's so funny.
I don't want him to throw.
That's so funny.
I love that.
I love that for him.
It's not evil, I'm just gaming the system.
I'm literally just gaming the system.
I'm touching, I'm touching.
It's all about the system, guys!
Oh my god.
Again!
Where's my again?
Oh, that's fucking right!
Get predicted!
Oh, you're gonna walk up to me?
What will you possibly do?
That's fucking right!
I deserve GM!
Oh no.
They got point back since when?
Oh my god, I had to reload.
I'm sorry.
I literally had to reload.
Oops, sorry.
I didn't realize he was asleep.
I can't see!
Wait, they lost the control again?
Oh, that was such a good hook.
That's actually such a good hook.
Gather around!
Friendship time!
Come on!
Oh no!
We lost one!
Nice!
Captain America!
Nice, we got it back!
The power of friendship!
Don't be a one trick!
Or I'll do what I did to Ross.
That's so fucking funny.
Hook is bad, why would you even ban him?
Says the Hulk one trick.
This is a threat.
Curse of Ra!
He was stunned.
He was like, bro, we were on the same team!
Yeah, the same team where we fucking lost!
That was my GM game, you fucker!
He's gonna do the Curse of Ra on me.
That's right, I learned.
I learned.
We cursed him.
What we need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Part of me just wants to get back home.
But I know I'm needed here.
Oh, wait a little.
Where are they?
Right side, right side.
Oh shit, that's where they are.
Oh shit.
That's where they were.
That's okay.
Everybody is okay.
It's okay.
He's so healthy.
You want to reload?
I'm so sorry.
If I didn't have to reload...
You could have lived with us!
Alright, you're gonna have to back up a little bit.
Oh no.
Here we go.
You know what to do with that!
Okay, apparently not.
Just stay there, stay there, stay there!
Stay there!
Stop!
Nevermind.
We didn't stay there.
Alright, we gotta go back.
It's okay.
Our Moon Knight is alive.
I realized Moon Knight is basically just Marvel Reaper.
He's so fucking edgy.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Oh, I can't see you.
I can't see you.
I hope you're getting them.
I hope you killed them.
He didn't kill them.
I hoped but nothing happened.
I feel like I hear them.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, I hear.
I hear our deaths.
Oh my god.
I was like, I'm ready to die here.
Team up?
Oh, my team up is gone.
Why?
Oh, Psylocke.
Oh, Venom.
Venom and Psylocke.
Oh, double tank.
I just realized we were solo tanking this entire time.
No!
It's okay.
We have ult for next round, right?
No.
No, I banned Hulk.
I might lose this now.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Ross is on DPS now?
It's because I put Ross on DPS.
Oh, my god.
Oh, no.
They are no longer one drinking.
No.
Maybe I should have banned Hulk.
Yes, he's bald.
No!
You made that man adapt.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
He has the most deaths, though.
So, I don't think he's actually adapting.
He's actually getting carried by his team.
He's not adapting.
What happened to the portal?
Now, we're going to be there late.
They must have been like, where are they?
Little do they know.
Our portal didn't work.
We fucked up the portal.
Little do they know.
That's bad, though.
Because they have the advantage.
Can you get that man to figure out if she wants to go left or right?
I'm like, looking left and right because he's...
What?
That hits me?
Okay,
I shouldn't just stand here because I realize if I just stand there it's just easier to fucking kill me.
Oh, thank God.
I was going to say, I just did like the sickest fucking move.
I just did like one of the sickest fucking moves possible.
Just to like, get trolled like that.
I would have been so fucking sad.
Come on, God.
Kill Captain America.
He's so...
No way!
They got the heal off.
No way.
No fucking way.
No fucking way!
Oh my God!
Why did we fuck?
No!
Guys...
I banned Hulk but it was no...
I got karma'd for banning Hulk, guys.
I actually got karma'd for it.
Who would have thought?
We didn't kill!
Thank God.
I was going to be so mad if we didn't kill her.
I was going to be like, there's no fucking way we didn't.
You're fucking welcome.
We have one fight.
Okay.
Okay, my ice aren't been on point though.
Not gonna lie.
Who's monkey?
Wait, we don't have point yet?
Oh no!
Okay, that's fine.
I used damage boost.
That's fine.
That...
We killed nothing.
That's fine.
This is not good.
No way!
There's no fucking...
Oh my God!
The curse of...
Rawr!
Oh
my God!
That's actually crazy!
How did I fumble?
I did my job!
I literally did my job!
Someone didn't do their job!
I did what my role was required to do.
I got cursed so raw.
I can't believe I actually got cursed so raw.
I should...
Cloak and dagger would not have helped us.
We needed a double...
We needed a defensive ult.
Sweet karma.
I knew it.
I had that feeling.
I was like, it's gonna happen.
I'm gonna be so excited that I banned...
That I banned a one trick character.
Because we lost because of it.
But it didn't even matter.
It didn't even matter.
Wait, why do I have...
Oh, they have two diamond one plays.
That's actually crazy.
I can't believe that happened.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe the captain lived for so fucking long.
Like, nobody killed her.
Or him.
Nobody killed him.
What's wrong with people?
I'm not banning.
I don't care enough to ban.
The last time I banned...
I strategically banned.
I lost.
I fucking...
That's the last time.
The last time I do it.
That was karma.
Actual karma.
And thus, I will never do it again.
Never.
One game.
I think that was...
Yeah.
That was so close.
It was one game.
Stop kicking their chair, karma.
That was the most fucking ridiculous thing I've ever heard.
In terms of parenting.
Just say it's bad.
You don't have to be like, karma's gonna get you.
If you kick this lady's chair, you're gonna fucking die.
Just be like, it's rude.
You don't have to tell her about karma.
Bro, that kid's too young to learn about fucking karma.
Stop them from securing the mission area.
Portal.
They're doing a portal.
What the hell does that mean?
Like,
I knew they were doing a portal, but it still scared me.
I was just like...
I didn't think it would be like that way, you know?
I was like, oh, portal.
And then it was like, on the...
That was such a...
Not weird, but like...
You gotta figure out where exactly they're gonna portal.
Yeah, I like...
That's fine, you're fine.
Sorry, Mantis.
If you die, you die.
I had to pick.
I'm sorry, Mantis.
Oh my god.
They were everywhere.
Mantis, you should have played with us.
Why didn't you 1v1 him?
You did not have to 1v1 him.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
I don't know why you 1v1 him.
Why did you 1v1 him?
Why?
If you 1v1 him, if you didn't 1v1 him, I would have been alive.
I would have been so fucking alive.
Oh, no.
No.
We double support Alston.
We have two good reflexes.
Our reflexes are too good.
No.
We would not have lived through that.
Even with two support ults, we would not have lived through that.
There was no way.
I don't think there was no living.
I don't even know how we can live through that.
Like, what kind of ult would let us live through that?
Like, there was no ult that could have saved us from that hellhole.
There was no ult.
Oh, no.
No, I'm alive?
I'm not alive.
Guys, I think it was the curse of Ross.
I think it was the curse of Ross.
Guys, I got curse of Ross, guys.
I got curse of Ross.
All because of that one guy.
All because of him.
It was his fault.
Don't do not.
Okay, thank God.
Oh, thank God.
He didn't.
Oh, it's because he didn't have the support.
Um, there's guys.
Oh, thank God I'm alive.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, thank God Mattison, Avholt, and I had ult there.
So we could do that.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, no!
No!
Not the moon!
Bro, that ult combo was actually crazy.
The fucking moon.
Like, I don't think there's any way to counter it.
I'm on it.
Goodbye.
Don't stack.
Wow, that sounds so easy.
It kills every support ult other than revive.
Oh, the cloaking dagger?
Nope, because the moon ult lasts too long.
We need to call it better.
Luna
doesn't outheal that.
We just Luna does not outheal that.
I'm fucking I have too much experience.
Yeah, there's nothing you can do.
Yeah, we just die.
Nothing outheals it.
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
Don't forget, securing the mission area is your top priority.
I can't rez it because like we need these heals.
We're taking so much damage and Adam's fucking heals do not sustain us.
I just, I've accepted it.
I've just accepted it.
I just
Please Please Kill him!
Kill him!
Is that Moon Knight?
They have Moon Knight.
There we go.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Why are you running, bitch?
That's fucking right.
Oh shit, I got a little too overconfident there.
Oh my god, what are you doing?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can't reach him!
He's too far up!
Oh, it's fine.
It's not fine.
Oh, it's definitely- Oh!
I thought the Mantis was gonna ult.
Alright.
It's fine.
We're so fine.
What's that sound?
It's like- Guys, I just need I just need three games.
Three games and I'll be Grandmaster, guys.
Just three easy games, guys.
Three such easy games.
Just three very easy games, guys.
Oh!
That's awkward.
No!
That's so awkward.
She was frozen!
How was I supposed to- This Mantis and I, we're not on the same wavelength.
We're not- We have no chemistry, this Mantis and I.
It's not you.
No, it is you.
I'm playing the game of my life right now.
It is you.
You've died eight times, Mantis.
It's not me.
I'm not the problem here.
I'm literally playing so well.
It can't be me.
We just have zero chemistry and it's just- It's just- It just be like that.
It just be like that.
We just, you know...
I literally have less deaths than you, so it can't be a me issue.
I can feel the moon.
I can feel the moon, guys.
I feel the moon coming in any moment.
The moon!
I feel it.
I
felt the moon.
The moon looked back at me.
Oh my god.
The moon!
We're alive!
We are alive!
Surefour!
We're actually alive!
Holy shit, it's fucking going a miracle round right now.
Jesus Christ!
The moon is hitting really hard right now.
I think we're dead.
Venom, please!
I can't jump that high!
Oh shit, let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Get that thing!
Oh no, the moon.
The moon's here.
The moon.
Kill him!
Kill him before the moon hits!
Kill him before it hits!
Please!
Bro, not the moon!
No!
I hate the moon!
The fucking moon!
Stupid moon!
I hate the moon.
I wanna blow up the moon.
I wanna blow it up.
The fucking moon!
That was so rough!
GG's.
GG's game.
Is he out of top 500?
GG's.
That's where I call it too.
We're gonna steal the fucking moon.
We're gonna recreate Despicable Me.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
That was great though.
That was a fun game.
I like checked SharePoint's chat and someone was like Throws Jokey's game Go to bed, Giga Chad.
That's a good quote.
I will admit that's actually a really good quote right there.
Bro!
What a fucking chat.
This is basically the quote of the day right here.
The moon!
The fucking moon!
The stupid fucking moon.
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
Guys, this is how I celebrate.
Okay, guys?
You're celebrating by playing Yes, that's exactly it.
We celebrate by playing Marble Rivals.
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
Anyway, I want to say congratulations again, Dragoons, for winning Best Fanbase of the Year.
I don't know if we could keep the title for Best Fanbase because by keeping the title, that means more fucked up shit is supposed to happen.
That's what I worry about.
I was like, what's gonna happen to me next year?
What's gonna happen to me?
Doki, no!
No, we're fine.
Please don't say that.
What's the damage for next year?
We win again.
What kind of character development am I gonna go through this time?
That was fun.
Congratulations again.
Huge support with everything.
The concert.
Watching me play Marble Rivals.
I don't have a problem.
I'm playing more Marble Rivals after this stream.
I'm gonna see if I can get Grandmaster tonight.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you, guys.
I hope you guys have a great time.
I'm gonna rest now as I'm gonna play Marble Rivals and then tomorrow we have a sponsored stream and then we're chilling after that.
I don't know when I'll be back fully for now because I need to relax after such a long, long time of working.
Maybe I'll be back next week.
We'll see how the schedule goes.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me?
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, yeah.
Check out my Nendoroid.
Nendoroid, Nendoroid.
Buy it, buy it, buy it.
I'll see you guys.
Bye.